so I was I was and I I am how to say
positional player but active positional
player so we had a purely positional
player who was Tigran Petrosian world
champion not for six years but i had to
active positional style and so now I
played my pie plate quite strongly
endings so this was my my advantage also
and then I could different difficult
positions which is quite seldom in
modern chess so and I could resist in in
positions where other players probably
would resign and I was I was finding
interesting interesting ideas how to how
to defend difficult positions and I
could save many games so I never gave up
I was okay I was stubborn as a chess
player and so I I try to defend even
very bad positions and in many cases
succeeded
as a personality and fighter you know
and I don't give up and if I believe I'm
i'm correct I'm right then then I rock
and I fight okay this could be over
chessboard it could be in life and so I
defend my principles and in chess and
chest okay this is my special special
how to say characteristic when you when
you try to find the best move whatever
position is because many people they say
okay this is bad and then they they lose
the will to fight I never lost will to
fight
this is a very important and this is
good question because many people would
would would call back the situation okay
they miss chances and then of course it
will spoil their the rest of the game
now but it is concerning concerning not
only special situation during the game
but also the bad result of previous game
for the next for the next game you play
so in my life I I tried and I succeeded
in many cases to forget everything what
was in the past so of course you need to
make some analysis and not to repeat
mistakes but it's extremely important to
accept situation like it is the real
situation not with the thoughts and
regrets what what you missed and okay
two months ago you had been in position
now you have to defend difficult
position and probably you you might lose
the game so this sort shouldn't
shouldn't be when you play when you play
chess game so later on maybe you analyze
and then you you you know how to see
then you make some conclusions but
during the game and this is also very
important part for for chess educator
because chess chess is giving ideas how
to accept how to accept a real situation
and to be to be objective to be
objective and to meet unexpected
situations and to adapt this immediately
and to start to sink and to solve the
problems you have to develop this so I
don't think it comes from from your
childhood or with your boss